la voiture que nous conduiront demain et
probablement en phase d'élaboration ici
à satory l'un des sites où est basé vd
comme l'institut pour la transition
énergétique est créée en 2014 travaille
actuellement sur près d'une vingtaine de
projets et profite de son troisième
anniversaire pour les faire découvrir à
ses partenaires nous disons que nous
voulons être l'écosystème qui génèrent
ces nouvelles mobilités l'écosystème de
référence et nous voulons être le
pionnier de ces nouvelles mobilités vd
comme compte désormais 150
collaborateurs pour développer ces
différents axes de recherche comme
l'électrification des véhicules
objectifs permettent de réduire la
consommation d'énergie et les émissions
de polluants principe à l'inauguration
cette année la piste qui recharge
directement la batteries des voitures
électriques
on peut l'imaginer au travers de la
charge en roulant qu'elle soit continu
comme on le fait sur la piste fabrique
coupe ce soit en biberonnage c'est à
dire avoir des spots où on charge quand
on s'arrête on peut effectivement
imaginer se déplacer sans consommer
d'énergie sur la batterie doté d'un
budget de 25 millions d'euros annuels bd
comme poursuit son développement l'an
prochain l'ensemble de ces activités
seront rassemblés à satory dans des
nouveaux locaux